-Well, good news, you guys.
Today is National Tequila Day.
Whoo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
And after six hours of Robert
Mueller testifying,
I think we all deserve it.
Doble, por favor.
[ Laughter ]
Actually, I saw that a lot
of bars in Washington
opened at 8:00 a.m. this morning
for the Mueller hearings.
If you did a shot any time
Mueller said
"I can't answer that," you were
blacked out by 10:00 a.m.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"I'm getting redacted today,
man."
That's right. It was a big event
on Capitol Hill.
Three months after
he released his report,
Mueller went to Congress
to answer some tough questions
about his investigation.
I don't want to say watching it
was draining,
but by the end, every American
looked like Robert Mueller.
[ Laughter ]
Let's talk about the hearings,
though.
They were pretty intense.
Mueller was questioned by 60
lawmakers for six hours.
The only other time
you get grilled like that
is if you're single
at your famry reunion.
[ Laughter ]
Famry rerunion. Family reunion.
Gosh!
You think that's funny, man?
[ Laughter ]
Unbelievable. Unbelievable.
You think that's funny.
That's the first joke you
laughed at all night, man.
[ Laughter ]
Famry --
Family reunion.
-Fammy reunion.
-[ Mumbling ]
[ Laughter ]
It's almost like I was playing
my record backwards.
[ Mumbling ]
Family rerunion.
Famry rerunion.
[ Imitating record scratching ]
♪♪
No.
[ Cheers and applause ]
No. It's terrible.
It's like Sylvester Stallone
doing the monologue.
[ As Stallone ] Fammy weunion.
Fammy reuyun.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I just had a family reunion.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
But the fireworks started early.
Mueller said the reason
that he couldn't charge Trump
with a crime was because
he can't indict
a sitting president.
That's why for the last 12
hours,
Trump's been afraid
to get up from the couch.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's right. Mueller said that
Trump couldn't get indicted
because he's in office.
But the president
is not out of the woods yet.
Listen to this.
-Could you charge the president
with a crime
after he left office?
-Yes.
-Hmm.
[ Audience oohs ]
So Trump could be charged after
he's done being president.
Right now in Russia, Putin's
looking at his phone like,
[ Russian accent ]
"Any second now.
Hello, Donald. Yes, I can help."
[ Laughter ]
A lot of people are focusing on
all the things
Mueller didn't say.
Instead of talking,
he just kept telling lawmakers
to go back and read his report.
Then the lawmakers were like,
"the whole point of us
bringing you here was so that we
didn't have to read the report.
Come on, talk!"
That's right. Mueller avoided
a lot of questions.
Take a look at this.
-I'm not going to get into what
we may or may not have included.
I'm not going to speculate.
That's beyond my purview.
That was outside our purview.
That's not in my purview.
-Yeah.
He's like a magic 8-ball,
except no matter how you shake
him, he just says,
"That's not in my purview."
[ Laughter ]
A lot of people in the media
are saying that Mueller
came across as old and slow.
On the bright side,
he's now the favorite
to win the Democratic nomination
for president.
[ Laughter ]
That's pretty good.
[ Applause ]
But I really can't blame Mueller
for having trouble keeping up.
Listen to what happened
when these first Republican
promised to talk slowly.
-I'll talk slowly.
I'm said that I talk fast.
I will talk slowly.
Your report states that
your investigative team
included 19 lawyers
and approximately 40 FBI agents
and analysts and accountants.
Are those numbers accurate?
-Could you repeat that, please?
[ Laughter ]
-Is it also true that you issued
over 2,800 subpoenas,
executed nearly 500 search
warrants,
obtained more than 230 orders
for communication records
and 50 pin registers?
-That went a little fast for me.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my goodness.
That's like being interviewed
by an auctioneer.
It's like, "Hey, we're going to
start the bidding at 19 lawyers,
40 FBI agents --
[ Calling ]
Going once, going twice!
Sold to the gentleman
in the back!"
If that guy did
all the questioning,
the hearing would have been over
in six minutes.
A lot of people laughed at this.
At one point,
Mueller had a little trouble
with the president's name.
Watch this.
-Did your investigation find
that the Russian government
perceived it would benefit from
one of the candidates winning?
-Yes.
-And which candidate
would that be?
-Well, it would be Trimp --
uh, Trump.
[ Laughter ]
-Then Trump was like,
[ As Trump ] "See,
it was Trimp who obstructed.
[ Laughter ]
Not Trump, Trimp.
Lock him up.
Lock up Trimp."
[ Laughter ]
The clip went viral,
which explains this yard sign
I saw today --
Trimp-Pince, 2020.
-Wow!
-Yeah, he changed his name.
-Pince.
-After the testimony,
both sides tried to declare
victory.
And Trump sent out a tweet
that said,
"Truth is a force of nature."
People were like,
"Wow, that's deep."
And Trump was like, "Thanks,
I got it from a fortune cookie."
[ Laughter ]
If you missed Mueller's hearing,
don't worry.
In a few weeks, William Barr
will give a much shorter,
inaccurate summary. Um...
[ Scattered laughter ]
You didn't like that joke?
It's okay.
You don't have to like 'em all.
-Come on, that was a good joke.
-You don't have to like
all of them.
It's okay.
-That's a good joke!
-But after all the hype
and questioning,
I don't think anybody's changed
their mind about anything.
Democrats are still thinking
about impeachment.
Republicans are still
saying case closed.
America hasn't been this divided
since the trailer
for the "Cats" movie came out.
[ Laughter ]
One of the Republicans laying
into Mueller the most today
was Mike Johnson.
This is interesting,
Mike Johnson --
-Excuse me, Mr. Fallon,
what did you mean when you said
America hasn't been this divided
since the "Cats" trailer?
-I'm sorry, Higgins, what?
-Earlier joke, you stated,
and I quote,
"America hasn't been
this divided
since the 'Cats' trailer
came out."
Can you elaborate on that?
-I'm sorry, which -- which joke?
-I'm referring to cue card 12,
joke 3-A.
"'Cats' trailer came out."
Explain what you meant, please.
-What -- No, I'm not going to
explain the joke.
You can just --
-Refer to your earlier
monologue. Yeah, I thought --
We thought you'd say that.
Anyway. Next --
-Who is we?
-Next question.
Do you recall a joke, February
2013,
where the punch line was,
and I quote,
"Chicken chalupa?"
[ Laughter ]
-Chicken chalupa?
I mean, maybe I --
-And what did you mean by that?
-It was 2013, Higgins.
I don't remember.
-What did you mean, Mr. Fallon?!
Chicken chalupa!
-That's out of my purview.
-Hey!
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's my time!
You shut your cute mouth.
[ Laughter ]
Final question --
June 18, 2019.
You said, and I quote,
"Without Fox News,
Trump's only source of news
is Snapple caps."
[ Laughter ]
What was that in reference to?
-I -- I never said that.
-You didn't say that
on June 18th?
-No, I never said that.
-Oh, wait a second.
[ Chuckles ]
That's on me.
That was a Colbert joke.
[ Laughter ]
-You like that joke?
-Yeah. That's a funny joke.
[ Applause ]
-That was a funny joke.
Steve Higgins, everyone.
No more questions!
Finally, listen to this --
A pair of Nike shoes
were just auctioned off
for a record $430,000.
Can we see the shoes?
This is real.
[ Laughter ]
One day the buyer will show his
kids and say,
"These are the reason you
couldn't go to college."
[ Laughter and applause ]
We have a great show.